steht russland vor seiner größten
wirtschaftskrise der letzten 20 40 70
oder er 120 jahre wird die russische
wirtschaft in der lage sein diesen
tsunami zu überstehen wie weit sind die
verbündeten bereit zu gehen am ein
riesen videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
dass russland ein beispielloser absturz
bevorsteht und die frage nur noch lautet
wie die das land fallen wird also
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
moskau hat den größten angriffskrieg in
europa seit 1945 losgetreten eine
militäroffensive die uns mit bildern
konfrontiert von denen viele dachten
dass wir sie in europa nie wieder sehen
würden tja so kann man sich irren aber
das hätte nicht passieren müssen wenn
die verantwortlichen politiker zb unsere
videos erfolgt hätten in denen wir schon
seit langem vor genau diesen
entwicklungen gewarnt haben nun jetzt
ist das kind in den brunnen gefallen
panzer schwerer artillerie luftkämpfe
und die bombardierung von stetten voller
unschuldiger menschen sind wieder da der
westen lässt sich mit angeblichen
atomkriegs boo boo boo einschüchtern und
die gas abhängigen deutschen haben angst
um ihre belege nestwärme natürlich wurde
putin dieses mal nicht nur mit dem
jubelte anerkennung und den beifall der
russischen bevölkerung für seine siege
auf dem schlachtfeld bedacht sondern
müsste gleichzeitig bei der westlichen
welt öffentlichkeit einen riesigen
tsunami von empörung und verurteilungen
aus denn auch zu dramatischen verlusten
bestrafen aus der ganzen welt führte
die russische invasion in der ukraine
markiert einen wendepunkt sie bedroht
unsere gesamte nachkriegsordnung in
dieser situation ist es unsere pflicht
der ukraine nach besten kräften zu
helfen sich gegen die invasionsarmee von
wladimir putin zu verteidigen olaf
scholz deutsche bundeskanzlerin wir
werden zeigen dass eine rücksichtslose
akt der gewalt einen hohen preis hat die
beziehungen der internationalen
gemeinschaft von russland können nicht
mehr so sein wie früher homoki china
japanischer premierminister die
alliierten warnten russland immer und
immer wieder der grausam und
ungerechtfertigte einmarsch in die
ukraine würde verheerende folgen für
dessen gesellschaft wirtschaft und auch
für die russische armee selbst haben
und so werden wir euch mein leben bis
zur politik zuschauer in diesem video
genau erklären wie die vereinigten
staaten die europäische union und im
allgemeinen alle verbündeten der nato
versuchen die wirtschaft und einen
großteil der macht russland zu schädigen
zu untergraben und sogar zu zerstören
und das obwohl der russische problem der
auch in zukunft ein wichtiger exporteur
von erdöl erdgas und rohstoffen sein
wird der deutsche kanzler olaf scholz
leistet so quasi den sicherheits
strategischen offenbarungseid als er
sagte die versorgung des landes mit
energie können im moment nicht anders
gesichert werden als mit russischen
gasimporten
diese existenzbedrohende abhängigkeit
von einem feindlich gesinnten aggressor
führt uns nun mit vollem ausmaß das
brutale an hochverrat grenzende versagen
seiner vorgänger vor augen in deren
regierungen scholz jedoch auch schon als
minister und vizekanzler saß und somit
deutlicher mitverantwortung trägt doch
dazu und zum masterplan für den
langfristigen gas ausstieg an dem die
task force des neuen deutschen
wirtschaftsministers habeck arbeitet
später mehr denn die herausforderungen
sind enorm
die muss jeder spagat aussehen mit dem
wladimir putin aufgehalten werden so
ohne der europäischen wirtschaft selbst
das genick zu brechen die bestrafen die
verbündeten russland für den überfall
der ukraine all diese für die weitere
zukunft des europäischen kontinents
lebenswichtigen fragen werden wenn
diesem video genau unter die lupe nehmen
[Musik]
die verengung russlands aus der
weltwirtschaft
bevor wir jedoch tiefer in die materie
einsteigen würde ich euch nur noch mal
kurz auf eine möglichkeit hinweisen der
vom krieg platten ukraine zu helfen die
zentralbank der ukraine nimmt spenden
aus der ganzen welt entgegen um mit
ihnen gezielt die ukrainischen
streitkräfte und den ukrainischen
widerstand zu unterstützen dies soll
keine werbung darstellt und natürlich
bis die man dafür wird tun dies nur weil
er davon überzeugt sind dass dieser weg
zur zeit der effektivste ist schließlich
wissen die ukraine selbst was sie vor
ort am nötigsten brauchen und dafür
benötigten sie eben finanzielle mittel
so und nun setzt die helme auf und für
teure stiefel natürlich nur im
sprichwörtlichen senden wir begeben uns
jetzt an die heiße front des
wirtschaftskrieg
[Musik]
der krieg wird an vielen verschiedenen
fronten geführt und eine davon ist eben
die des wirtschafts kriegs die usa
großbritannien und die europäische union
war sich darüber im klaren dass ein
einmarsch putins in die ukraine eine
noch nie da gewesene bestrafung
russlands nach sich ziehen müsse und
wisst ihr was hingegen dem was wir in
der vergangenheit von wiesen sachtleben
gewohnt waren schritt man sofort zur tat
nicht nur um zu versuchen den krieg zu
beenden sondern auch und vielleicht vor
allem um die bedrohung durch die macht
und den einfluss russlands langfristig
einzudämmen
wenn der verlauf der invasion in der
ukraine etwas deutlich gemacht hat dann
dass einem land mit weniger ressourcen
letztlich viele grenzen gesetzt sind
unzureichende versorgung alter
ausrüstung schlechte ausbildung oder
eine lange liste anderer probleme aller
art und wie viel propaganda auch immer
betrieben wird am ende kommt die
realität zum vorschein russland ist ein
relativ armes und hochgradig coop das
land das gilt für alle bereiche auch
sein militär so großes auch ist hat mehr
löcher als ein schweizer käse wie wir
alle mittlerweile auf unzähligen von
ukrainern vor ort hochgeladenen handy
videos gesehen haben machen die
russischen streitkräfte auf militär
verraten und dem papier es war eine
ausgezeichnete figur leiden dann aber
unter allen möglichen unzulänglichkeiten
wenn es wirklich darauf ankommt der
krieg ist eben das ultimative manöver
und das alles hat natürlich drastische
konsequenzen so weisen quellen darauf
hin dass die russen allein in den ersten
fünf sechs tagen invasion der ukraine
mehr opfer zu beklagen hatten als die
vereinigten staaten in 20 jahren
afghanistan-krieg aber abgesehen vom
physischen kampf geht es für euch
bereits gesagt haben darum putin zu
bestrafen und russlands wirtschaftskraft
einzuschränken solange russland bei uns
bleibt natürlich werden viele von euch
sagen jaja mal jetzt geht's los mit den
üblichen gratis mutigen und
neunmalklugen kommentaren über geo
strategie und pipapo aber wenn es dann
zur sache geht kommt praktisch nichts
dabei heraus nun ihr könnt mir glauben
wenn ich euch sage das ist den
verbündeten diesmal wirklich sehr sehr
ernst ist denn der einmarsch in die
ukraine hat alles verändert und deshalb
war es ihr erstes ziel russland aus dem
internationalen finanzsystem zu kicken
erstens soll die sanktionen die auslands
finanzierung für die russische regierung
russische banken und unternehmen
ersticken um dies zu erreichen haben die
verbündeten beschränkungen beim kauf von
anleihen und sanktionen gegen die
wichtigsten banken des landes
beschlossen so haben die usa unter
anderem die beiden größten banken des
landes die sberbank und vtb die zusammen
fast 60 prozent des russischen
finanzsystems kontrollieren mit einem
boykott belegt so dass sie nicht mehr
mit us banken zusammenarbeiten können
mit anderen worten sie können keine
geschäfte in dollar abwickeln
[Musik]
und natürlich werden die meisten
internationalen geschäfte eben in dollar
abgewickelt aber es geht nicht nur um
die usa großbritannien oder die
europäische union haben nachgezogen und
dieses gemeinsames vorgehen hat russland
erschüttert natürlich zunächst nur die
finanzmärkte ein schneeball der dort
jedoch losrollt wird im tal in der
realwirtschaft mit ein wenig verzögerung
als lawine ankommen
die zweite maßnahme wurde vielleicht mit
der größten spannung erwartet der
ausschluss vieler russischer banken aus
dem sogenannten swift system das
internationale nachrichtensystem dass
die meisten banken der welt miteinander
verbindet dürfte eine in belgien
ansässigen genossenschaft ist ein
interbanken kommunikationssystem das
dann mehr als der hälfte aller
grenzüberschreitenden großen
überweisungen beteiligt ist täglich
werden mehr als 40.000 transaktionen
zwischen mehr als 11.000
finanzinstituten weltweit verarbeitet
nun wird ein großer teil der russischen
banken von diesem system ausgeschlossen
werden und achtung 1 2012 iranische
banken aus rift ausgeschlossen würden
war das eine katastrophe für das ganze
land kürzlich konnten sie keine
internationalen überweisungen abwickeln
weil sie nicht mehr kommunizieren oder
diese überprüfen konnten im falle
russlands werden nicht alle banken
betroffen seien zumindest nicht
vollständig schließlich wollen die
europäer weiterhin russisches öl und gas
kaufen und sie müssen in lage sein dafür
zu zahlen hinzu kommen die schulden die
die russen bei westlichen banken gemacht
haben und die sie natürlich wieder
eintreiben wollen wir sprechen hier von
121 milliarden dollar ob sie dieses geld
jedoch so schnell wieder sehen werden
ist fraglich
[Musik]
russland hat sein unternehmen verboten
diese kredite in devisen zu bedienen sie
sollen nur noch mit dem hobel bezahlen
der jedoch jeden tag immer weiter in der
wertlosigkeit versinkt allein während
der ersten zehn tage des sanktionen ist
sein wert um 50 prozent gegenüber dollar
und euro eingebrochen trotz der
ausnahmen beim pid boykott wird der
schaden für das russische finanzsystem
also näher als beträchtlich sein da es
alternativen gibt diese aber teurer sind
kontroll problem mit sich bringen und
viele banken für ihre nutzung nie
entschädigt werden so oder so werden die
ausgeschlossenen russischen banken
keinen zugang mehr so einen bedeutenden
teil des weltweiten finanzsystems haben
was wir euch vorstellen könnt den handel
auslandsinvestitionen oder auch die
verwaltung von überweisungen
komplizierter und teurer machen wird mit
anderen worten das haben sie sich um
einen gewaltigen tritt gegen das
schienbein der russischen wirtschaft
[Musik]
über das chinesische system cifs können
nämlich nur zahlung in julians
verarbeitet werden welche noch nicht mal
zwei prozent aller weltweiten
transaktionen ausmachen gegenüber 40
prozent in dollar es war nie dafür
gedacht trifft zu ersetzen sondern ist
auf eine enge vernetzung mit ihm
angewiesen russland verfügt zwar über
verschärfen im jahr hat aber gerade
jetzt einen wesentlich stärkeren bedarf
an westlichen devisen um die paar
handelspartner die es noch hat zu
befriedigen deshalb wird russland jetzt
paradoxerweise versuchen sicherzustellen
dass es verkäufe in china in dollar oder
euro abgewickelt werden damit wird die
ging jedoch ganz und gar nicht
einverstanden seien deswegen ehren
zurzeit zahlreiche öltanker voll
russischen öls über die weltmeere als
hätten sie sauerbier geladen niemand
will das zeug die papierlosen
handelspartner wie russland jetzt noch
übrig bleiben werden die notlage des
landes natürlich maximal zu ihren
eigenen gunsten ausnutzen ihr gegenüber
bis zum letzten blutstropfen aussaugen
[Musik]
moskau bleiben also kaum noch spielräume
weswegen internationale ratingagenturen
das praktisch die industrialisierte land
30 jetzt kurz vor der
zahlungsunfähigkeit sehen und
schließlich kam noch der dritte schlag
der ausschluss aufschrift ist zwar die
spektakulärste aktion aber die
eigentliche bombe war die entscheidung
der usa der eu großbritanniens kanadas
und weitere länder könnten folgen die
russische zentralbank und damit einen
großteil ihrer internationalen reserven
zu blocken wie wir in einem früheren
video berichtet haben sind einer der
größten treffen mit putin ist die
vermögens- reserven im wert von mehr als
600 milliarden dollar die russen über
viele jahre in form von dollars euros
goldmann yen und so weiter und so fort
angehäuft hat
[Musik]
diese reserven waren eckpfeiler seiner
fest dunk russland strategie die wir
euch vorgestellt haben und mit der putin
sein land auf den krieg vorbereitet und
gegen sanktionen immun machen wollte
putin beginnen jedoch einen im wahrsten
wortsinn kapitalen fehler er verließ
sich darauf dass sein größtes
trojanisches pferd in europa die
deutsche regierung das einfrieren in
europa liegen der reserven verhindern
werde doch der druck auf berlin wurde zu
groß die bundesregierung kippte nach den
ihre amateurhafte hinhaltetaktik nicht
funktioniert hatte und wechselt dann
prompt das lager da hatten wohl einige
gemerkt dass man auch bei
rüstungsaufträgen ordentlich kickbacks
absahnen kann tja manchmal können
opportunismus und korruption doch sowas
gut sein und so ist jetzt ein großer
teil der riesigen kriegskasse putins
immerhin der fünftgrößte diesen schatz
der welt verschwunden zumindest kann die
russische regierung nicht mehr auf sie
zurückgreifen dies ist eine art
finanzielle atombombe die auf russland
fällt der krieg kam und das geld ging
aus es ging schneller aus als der krieg
zu ende war sergej alexejew maliger
stellvertreter finanzminister und
ehemalige stellvertretende gouverneur
der russischen zentralbank
bargeldreserven werden benötigt um
importe zu bezahlen und auch um die
landeswährung zu stützen so verfügt die
russische zentralbank angesichts der
durch den krieg und die sanktion
verursachten kapitalflucht und des
abschlusses von investitionen nicht mehr
über die notwendigen mittel um den rubel
vor spekulanten und dem totalen absturz
zu schützen dies wird den ganzen land
einen schweren schlag versetzen die
inflation wird in die höhe schießen die
realeinkommen werden einbrechen und die
ersparnisse der werde ersparnisse wird
sich ganz einfach in luft auflösen die
blockade der zentralbank hat der
russischen regierung plötzlich über
nacht den gegenwert von hunderten von
milliarden dollar anzogen es handelt
sich um eine maßnahme die bisher nur
gegen den iran venezuela und nordkorea
ergriffen wurde was für ein vornehmer
club den russland jetzt beigetreten ist
und ist bedarf nur eines kurzen blick in
diese länder um zu sehen wie russland
bald aussehen wird es überrascht also
nicht dass aldi ist die russische
regierung gezwungen hat drastische
extrem drastische maßnahmen zu ergreifen
[Musik]
kurz nach der ankündigung der
umfangreichen sanktionen versuchte die
russische zentralbank die kapitalflucht
und den daraus dass du dir den abschluss
des rubels einzudämmen dazu hob sie die
zinssätze von 0 95 prozent auf
sagenhafte 20 prozent an das hat
natürlich sehr negative auswirkungen auf
russische unternehmen und auch familien
denn verbraucherkredite sind in russland
sehr beliebt um es kurz und knapp zu
sagen ein so hoher leitzins ist für eine
wirtschaftlich sowieso nicht gerade
berauschend läuft der todesstoß eine
abwärtsspirale die das land in wenigen
monaten an einen punkt bringen wird an
dem sich die russen selbst an der
bernischen verhältnisse der neunziger
jahre mit wehmut erinnern werden
deswegen wollen viele russen ihr
vermögen natürlich so schnell wie
möglich ins ausland retten doch die
regierung für das strenge
kapitalverkehrskontrollen eigentlich
beispielsweise verhindern dass osten
ungehindert geld ins ausland schicken
können und die internationale investoren
daran hindern ihre beteiligungen auf den
russischen aktienmarkt zu liquidieren
russland machte am morgen des 28 2 2022
als finanztechnisch in einer udssr 20
auf und alle übrigen bereich des lebens
werden folgen tja mal sehen da in
nächster zeit noch so mutig sein wird in
russland zu investieren und vergesst
bitte nicht dass wir nur über die usa
großbritannien und die eu sprechen viele
andere länder wie japan südkorea
australien kanada norwegen und solar
singapur und die schweiz haben ebenfalls
sanktionen gegen russland zeigen ja ihr
habt euch nicht verhört sogar die
neutrale schweiz hat sich dem tritt
gegen putins schienbein angeschlossen
die schweiz unterstützt vollständig die
eu sanktionen gegen russland
norwegens 1,3 billionen dollar schwerer
11 uhr will sich von russischen
investitionen trennen als rache setzte
russland diese über 50 nationen nun auf
seine liste sämtlicher länder auf der
sich vorher nur die usa und tschechien
gefunden haben es war mit der zeit dann
doch etwas einsam geworden gut dass der
rest der welt die es endlich aufgewacht
ist aber das ist noch nicht alles denn
sobald die alliierten russland erst
einmal aus dem internationalen
finanzsystem ausgeschlossen haben wollen
sie es anschließend vollständig
isolieren also aufgepasst
[Musik]
russland so allein wie nie zuvor
neben den finanzsanktionen verhängt die
tabletten auch handelssanktionen die
russen beispielsweise daran hindern
kritische produkte wirklichen logisch
fortschrittliche komponenten zu kaufen
gleichzeitig veranlassten das risiko
wegen einige dieser sanktion zu
verstoßen sowie die angst vor einer
schlechten reputation viele unternehmen
dazu ihre aktivitäten in russland ganz
oder zu einem großen teil einzustellen
im grunde findet sich mittlerweile kein
westliches multinationales unternehmen
mehr dass in russland auf seine dienste
oder produkte anbieten will neben vielen
anderen zb volvo daimler disney apple
nike jaguar bp shell ikea ecuador intel
ibm ps fedex und adidas moment mal alias
das ende der sporting schlafs putin
warst hast du angerichtet
[Musik]
aber das ist quoten ist nicht die
einzige disziplin die daran glauben muss
darüber hinaus wird russland so gut die
weltweit von allen kulturellen und
sportlichen einrichtungen und
wettbewerbe ausschloss mit vom
eurovision song contest bis zur
fußballweltmeisterschaft
fifa und uefa suspendieren alle
russischen vereine und
nationalmannschaften und glaubt mir
ihrer sportler nicht mehr auf
internationalen wettbewerben siegen zu
sehen ist für die national stolzen
russen ein wirklich schmerzhafter und
demütigen der schlag wenn es jedoch
einen bereich gibt in dem schnell klar
wird was die isolierung russland
wirklich bedeutet dann ist es kein
anderer als die luftfahrt
[Applaus]
die europäische union die vereinigten
staaten großbritannien und kanada haben
ihren luftraum für russische flugzeuge
gesperrt unser luftraum wird für alle
russischen flugzeuge gesperrt auch für
die privat schätzt der oligarchen ursula
von der leyen präsidentin der
europäischen kommission und nicht nur
das nicht verbündeten haben auch strenge
beschränkungen für den verkauf aller
barren und technologien in zusammenhang
mit flugzeugen festgelegt mit anderen
worten wenn ein flugzeug nach russland
fliegt und dann dort ein problem hat
riskiert fluggesellschaft zu stranden
weil sie nicht in der lage ist die
benötigten teile zu bekommen aus diesem
grund haben auch viele internationale
fluggesellschaften aus anderen ländern
ihre flügel nach russland eingestellt
darüber hinaus hat die europäische union
flugzeug leasingunternehmen die
zusammenarbeit mit russischen
fluggesellschaften untersagt
das ist keine kleinigkeit denn wie in
der branche üblich sind mehr als die
hälfte verkehrsflugzeug in russland
geleast der russische luftraum wird für
lange zeit sehr leer sein und das kann
für ein derart riesiges land schwere
konsequenzen haben von moskau weit
entlegene regionen könnten abdriften und
außer kontrolle geraten
ein weiteres wichtiges schlachtfeld
spielt sich auch auf digitaler ebene ab
das hacker kollektiv anonymous erklärte
der russischen regierung den cyberkrieg
bisher legten sie website verschiedene
regierungsstellen darunter sogar die von
putins präsidialamt namen tauschten
deren inhalte aus und manipulierten auch
das programm staatliche fernsehsender
natürlich wollen auch die staatliche
neckar der alliierten aus allen rohren
hier ist das ziel sicher die kritische
infrastruktur innerhalb russlands daher
hat russland mit aktiven vorbereitungen
begonnen die landeseigene tcp ip wan
infrastruktur namens frunet vom rest der
welt abzuschneiden wohnt wurde schon
seit einigen jahren vorbereitet und es
wurde 2009 10 sogar schon ein probelauf
für einen solchen ernstfall durchgeführt
denn internet ist mittlerweile das
rückgrat der industrie und kommunikation
jedes landes ein solcher schritt der
selbstisolation hätte gravierende und
nur schwer absehbare folgen dieses thema
ist jedoch so umfassend dass wir es
lieber sein eigenes video auch sparen
also aber nicht vergessen und ebenfalls
ein oder vielleicht sogar mehrere eigene
videos werden wir den wichtigen thema
widmen wie die energieabhängigkeit
europas von russland erreicht werden
kann an dieser stelle wollen wir nur
kurz die aktuelle situation umreißen
denn auch wenn es viele nicht wahrhaben
wollen deutschland finanziert punkt
hills creek die zahlen lügen nicht im
jahr 2020 zahlte die über 64 milliarden
für mineral exporte an russland der
russische militär etat beträgt dabei
knapp 62 milliarden russland kann es
eine kriegsmaschinerie also komplett aus
den eu geldern finanzieren und wir
dürfen nicht vergessen erst das
ausbleibende rohstoffexport einnahmen
wird der kriegsmaschinerie des kreml die
luft zum atmen nehmen denn entgegen der
meinung vieler kommt dieses geld jetzt
bei den kleinen leuten in russland an
fast alles davon landet entweder in den
taschen der oligarchen oder in der
staatskasse von der aus es dann direkt
in die rüstung fließt der handel mit
energierohstoffen macht ein fünftel des
russischen staatshaushalt aus die hälfte
davon bezahlt die eu und der löwenanteil
davon kommt wiederum aus deutschland die
deutschen stecken also als financiers
bis zum hals in diesen krieg und das
obwohl schon seit 2014 klar war dass es
dringend geboten ist die fatale
energieabhängigkeit der größten europas
von russland zu eliminieren oder
wenigstens abzubauen doch stattdessen
tat die regierung merkel das genaue
gegenteil putin gelangt ist europa und
deutschland noch abhängiger zu machen
auch dank der exzellenten lobbyarbeit
von gas gerd daher haben wir euch in
einem unserer vorangegangen videos dazu
aufgerufen eure bundestagsabgeordneten
zu wirklich kategorische und
kompromisslosen schritten zu ermuntern
kanada hat bereits seine ersten einkäufe
aus russland komplett gestoppt auch die
usa haben angekündigt kein russisches öl
mehr zum rotieren und erhöhen ihren
druck auf die eu endlich nachzuziehen
der roboter baut diesen stieler putin
verstehe die es sich in ihrem warmen
stückchen gemütlich machen wollen
während sie über ihre gasrechnung das
abschlachten von zivilisten finanzieren
zieht also nicht mehr auch der
niederländisch-britische energiegigant
royal dutch shell hat den handel mit
russischem gas und öl eingestellt und
schließt und ausland seine komplette
geschäftstätigkeit inklusive des
tankstellennetzes und dass genau diese
maßnahmen nun den kritischen erstes
kreml treffen zeigt seine reaktion
zum ersten mal seit dem einmarsch in der
ukraine hat russland offen damit gedroht
die gaslieferung durch die nord stream
pipeline nach deutschland zu
unterbrechen wenn der westen die
russischen ölimporte verbietet daher
stellt sich jetzt gar nicht mehr die
frage ob sich deutschland vom russischen
blut gas unabhängig machen sollte
sondern nur wie schnell ein team von
gelehrten der nationalen akademie der
wissenschaften leopoldina hält die
auswirkungen eines kurzfristigen
lieferstopps für erdgas aus russland für
handhabbar für die deutsche
volkswirtschaft die experten denken
engpässe könnten sich zwar im kommenden
winter ergeben es bestünde jedoch die
möglichkeit durch die unmittelbare
umsetzung eines maßnahmenpakets die
negativen auswirkungen zu begrenzen und
sozial auswirkungen abzufedern genau das
was wir auch schon die ganze zeit
empfehlen daher hat die task force des
deutschen wirtschaftsministeriums jetzt
einen masterplan für den deutschen gas
ausstieg erarbeitet und dieser hat es in
sich insgesamt erhält er 18 vorschläge
für bundeszuschüsse an unterschiedliche
empfängergruppen das heizen von gebäuden
zum beispiel ist für 50 prozent des
erdgasverbrauchs gehen deutschlands
verantwortlich daher sind in diesem
bereich die aufwendigsten
fördermaßnahmen und regulierungen
geplant das konzept die langfristig auch
den verstärkten ausbau der
wasserstoffinfrastruktur und den import
von energieträgern auf wasserstoff basis
vor etwas wozu wir auch schon mehrere
videos gedreht haben ja wie gesagt dies
ist eines der heißesten themen dieses
ganzen konflikt sowohl kurz als auch
langfristig deswegen arbeiten wir hierzu
in einem video special dass wir so
schnell wie möglich veröffentlichen
werden und alles in allem muss man sagen
dass dan und wirklich sehr nah dran sein
dass russland vollständig und wirksam
aus der internationalen gemeinschaft
ausgeschlossen wird und zwar genau dort
wo er seinen häschern am meisten weh tut
nicht nur dem einfachen volk ohne geld
ohne kommunikation und mit drastischen
restriktionen aller art kann man sich
vorstellen wie die zukunft und
leistungsfähigkeit der russischen
wirtschaft aussehen wird ein szenario
dass russland in die sprichwörtliche
steinzeit zurückgeworfen wird ist gar
nicht mehr so abwegig auf jeden fall
wird ist eine niedergang auf das niveau
der 90er jahre erleben die
lebensleistung von millionen russen
dieser generation wird gerade ausradiert
und all das bedeutet dass die zukunft
eines russland unter putin sehr sehr
düster aussieht
[Musik]
das ist traurig und bitter aber so ist
es nun mal wenn man einen krieg loos
tritt und je schneller und drastischer
die maßnahmen erfolgen desto schneller
kann die krise überwunden werden desto
schneller kann es für alle wieder
bergauf gehen schließlich waren es das
zögern zaudern und opportunismus und die
gier demokratisch gewählter deutsche
politiker dieses protein ermöglicht
haben uns in diese schreckliche
situation zu bringen
daher ist es klar dass wir für diese
ziele auch einen preis zahlen müssen sie
müssen jedoch schnellstmöglich
korrigiert werden damit wir uns nach der
beendigung des russischen problembären
putin den wirklichen corinna im raum zu
wenden können china okay aber zwei
entscheidende teile des
sanktionsmaßnahmen haben wir noch gar
nicht angeschnitten dahin zusätzlich zu
all dem finanz- und handelssanktionen
hat das trio der wichtigsten verbündeten
der vereinigten staaten der europäischen
union und großbritannien auch russische
oligarchen die den kreml nahe stehen
sowie schwergewichte regierung ins
visier genommen gegen viele von ihnen
wird ermittelt ihr vermögen im ausland
wurde eingefroren und ein einreiseverbot
verhängt und wirst dir hast sogar monaco
hat sich diesen sanktionen angeschlossen
wir nehmen die privatiers der
oligarchischen ins visier nehmen ihre
immobilien ins gesäß unternehmen all
ihre anderen besitztümer ins visier
lässt das britische außenministerin ziel
ist es die präsenz aller putin an
oligarchischen aus der welt außerhalb
russlands zu tilgen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass diese leute und ihre
familien ihre in russland ergaunerten
milliarden yuan schöneren ordnung
genießen möchten als in totalitären
staaten in dem gerade das licht
ausgeknipst hat daher verwundert es
nicht dass sie nun ganz schnell den
angriffskrieg ihres meisters in frage
stellen zumindest nach außen hin
russische top oligarchen sprechen sich
gegen den krieg in der ukraine aus oh ja
sie werden das süße leben sicher
vermissen allerdings meine lieben
zuschauer dürfen wir nicht vergessen
dass dieser wirtschaftskrieg den die
alliierten ging russland führen eben nur
die zivile seite des konflikts darstellt
auf der anderen seite haben wir es immer
noch mit einem richtigen gewaltsamen
krieg zu tun daher erstreckt sich die
bestrafung russlands auch auf den
militärischen bereich also aufgepasst
waffen waffen und nochmals waffen
wladimir putin wirkte sehr sehr
selbstgefällig die ukrainische armee
würde seine überlegenen russische
streitmacht nicht gewachsen sein aber
wie wir alle wissen verläuft diese ganze
geschichte bisher ganz anders putins
potemkinsche truppen sind auf eine viel
robustere besser ausgerüstete und vor
allem wesentlich stärker motiviert army
gestoßen als sie dachten
und nicht nur das nach beginn der
invasion trafen nachschublieferungen der
nato und verbündeter länder ein als gäbe
es kein morgen zunächst zögerten länder
wie deutschland waffen an die ukraine zu
liefern es legte sogar sein veto gegen
die lieferung von waffen aus deutscher
produktion von ländern wie estland eine
doch dann änderte sich alles plötzlich
zeigte der druck der usa des vereinigten
königreichs polens und der baltischen
länder wirkung jetzt ist allen klar das
ist mit jedem tag an dem die ukraine
widerstand leisten können für russland
nur noch schlimmer werden wird
genau aus diesem grund kündigt die große
mehrheit der europäischen regierungen
massive waffenlieferungen an die
ukrainische armee an panzerabwehrraketen
luftabwehrsysteme munition lebensmittel
schutzwesten gewehre und so weiter und
so fort sogar die europäische union
selbst hat angekündigt dass sie ihren
friedens fonds zur finanzierung des
kaufs von rüstungsgütern für die ukraine
einsetzen wird dies ist das erste mal in
ihrer geschichte überhaupt dass die
europäische union mittel für den kauf
militärischer ausrüstung bereit stellt
all dies hat natürlich dazu geführt dass
die ukrainische armee besser in der lage
ist widerstand zu leisten oder
russischen armee großen schaden zufügt
eine armee für die jeder tag des kampfes
ein vermögen kostet ein vermögen das sie
nicht hat und die opferzahlen gehen auch
durch die decke
sogar das neutrale schweden hat sich
dieser groß angelegten kampagne
angeschlossen das skandinavische land
dazu gesagt mehr als 5000
panzerabwehrraketen tausende von
schutzwesten und helden sowie andere
ausrüstungen zu schicken denn auch die
schweden haben klar erkannt neutralität
muss wehrhaft sein sonst wird sie vom
bösen überrannt das gleiche gilt ja für
übertriebene nicht wehrhafte toleranz
all diese wichtigen werte sind nur dann
existenzfähig wenn sie nicht zu einer
selbstzerstörerischen lessings der
mentalität führen der begriff der
neutralität darf kein euphemismus für
feigheit vor dem feind sein letztlich
sind ist nämlich unsere demokratischen
und humanistischen werte welche die
stärksten waffen gegen das tyrannische
und menschenverachtendes system
darstellen dass putin und china als neue
weltordnung durchsetzen wollen in
unserem letzten video sprachen wir
darüber wie putin das russische volk
schon lange zeit militaristischen fort
so dass er nun auch den gang von der
blitzoperation zum totalen krieg ohne
große widerstände verkaufen kann wenn
wir uns dämlich mit der russischen
militärdoktrin beschäftigen stellen
schnell fest dass sich der bisherige
kriegsverlauf durchaus in ihrem rahmen
bewegt sie schließt den versuch eines
schnellen enthauptungsschlag sein ist
jedoch ebenfalls eines schalters
keineswegs mit ihrem latein am ende
nun kommen jede ihrer teils und tragen
welche wir auch aus anderen russischen
und sowjetischen personen kennen einen
langjährigen vernichtungskrieg welche
liegt erschlagen das feindlichen
streitkräfte und zivilgesellschaft zum
ziel hat wir dürfen hier nicht vom
westlichen ideal ausgehen dass es den
russen wichtig wäre einen krieg
möglichst schnell und schonend
durchzuziehen für sie ist tatsächlich
das ziel das ziel die brutal der weg
wird ist zweitrangig die russische
militärdoktrin definiert daher ein
langsames kraftvolles und
rücksichtsloses vorgehen
[Musik]
sie rechnet im rahmen eines
langandauernden zermürbungskrieg ganz
bewusst extrem hohe verluste und
opferzahlen ein sowohl in den eigenen
reihen als auch ein feind und bei der
zivilbevölkerung es wird putin auch
nichts ausmachen hunderttausende von
regime gegnern ins gefängnis zu werfen
und säuberungen in statistischer manier
sowohl in russland als auch in allen
eroberten gebieten sind nur der nächste
logische schritt das einzige was ihn
jetzt noch stoppen kann ist daher gewalt
oder das ihm und seiner armee materiell
der boden unter den füßen weggezogen
wird das können nur jene tun die seinem
terror zurzeit noch finanzieren also
herr scholz sie sitzen jetzt arm und
geldhahn putins tun sie das richtige
wenn sie es nicht tun wird das blut aber
tausende menschen für immer an ihren
händen kleben
aber jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der
reihe was haltet ihr von der strategie
der alliierten länder was sollten sie
eure meinung nach noch tun wird sie
funktionieren oder wird sie scheitern
kann russland all dies wegstecken oder
umgehen zb mit der hilfe chinas oder
indiens wie könnte dies verhindert
werden ihr seht jede menge stoff für
zukünftige videos und diskussion haut
also in die tasten ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video trotz eines düsteren haus
gefallen hat falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
leichter ist mit irgend freunden und
fans nicht das abo mit glöckchen um
keines unseren videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich wollen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit der er uns
hilft dieses projekt weiterzuführen in
peter link dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]